we'll see that on Election Day where
they use it enough and clearly they're
using technology as a whole host of
different ways that everybody does and
as a amount of money they raised over
the internet after Sarah Palin was
announced was extraordinary so they've
clearly got their sights set on how to
use technology will know on election day
whether they did them enough or not the
way of getting out a message is review
way of using the new techniques and the
new tools that are at hand to get a
message out to more than a few people I
have the blackberry I have an ipod i
have kindle I you have a I calling my
little man but he's my garmin in my car
that gets me from one place to another
so i use a lot of technology
you